okay for people who are joining this
livestream this is a discussion of a
future feature for Wolfram language
which actually I haven't seen for a very
long time so I'm excited to take a look
at this so I gather there's a slideshow
here maybe I should bring up the
slideshow yeah
this is a good slideshow so let's just
go through it okay let's do that okay
okay so these are all come on so is
extinct I'm joking okay these are all
examples that use microcontrollers and
the kind that we support so which of the
vendors typically Atmel Ti things like
that yes yes
who else SDM so there are
microcontrollers and they're also like
board board manufacturers so microchip
TI these are all microcontroller
manufactures and then there are people
who build on top of that like Adafruit
lululu and say okay right but that's
different from the market you know the
Raspberry Pi Beagle bone etc type market
where those are actual computers yeah
exactly yeah so these microcontrollers
yeah it's different because there's no
operating system yeah I understand so
what has been the trend of operating
system list devices well these date back
a long time but also today and when you
build them they're it's sort of two
levels so if you have a drown thing that
actually controls two motors for the
drone sure the things that we're gonna
talk about today all right flight
controllers as opposed to the main
braces right they're supposed to the
macro level that orchestrates the deals
with network connectivity that deals
with sort of commands coming in okay so
we see the macro level thing runs at a
very slow pace compared to these
what are the chemical clock frequencies
of these things the 16 megahertz 1
megahertz and so on so they're very slow
so I'm confused here so the point is
that running very simple code even
though the clock frequency is slow I
mean because a typical clock for a you
know microprocessor it gigahertz yeah
but this is on the metal signal
processing on the metal control these
are very simple codes they're real
they're hard real time if something goes
wrong there it goes horribly wrong
yeah yeah right so okay let me just
understand though I mean the trend
obviously as soon as you're running
neural net stuff you're running much
more general-purpose I mean people are
not trying to download that toward we
knows all right no no no but what's
happening the neural network stuff is is
in terms of deployment in real time
systems is getting there's a ton of
startups to the building hardware sort
of special purpose hardware and that's
that's very much not general purpose
controller computers they're they're
built for that to be fast and efficient
at doing that you know so you know the
tesla takes a kilowatt just to stand
still running the GPU that's gonna go
away right right
okay somebody on our live stream is
asking about esp8266 and ESP 32 not my
field what are those things yes so those
are different targets so those are
microcontrollers exactly yeah okay but
so I'm seeing various vendors listed
here but the the arm that thing and
that's not a microcontroller is it on
cortex that's that's an actual processor
well you can use variety you know so the
the the low-level ones don't use these
you know these are like 50 cent
processors you know yeah they're not the
$10 you know or fine
all right let's take a look here yeah so
here we dig down into into more detail
you can openers
okay see there are lots of hoverboards
sure this is just an example Stephen
okay okay
okay so what what we're showing here is
that you know there's that
microcontroller on the left and that's
doing a very specific task and so we can
generate an embed code I get it
okay now on the academic lab side what's
happened there is that there is sort of
a wholesale replacement going on on
these expensive boards from National
Instruments and other places to these
micro boards and that's happening both
at the high school level where you have
maker labs and it's happening at the
university level this is obviously a
Batmobile
well sure okay okay thanks I get it this
I I'm sure you've seen the video gram
before in systems development but so
this is how you develop an airplane or a
rocket or something like that it's
typically following this development
model I'm saying it's getting very very
concrete there at the bottom
yeah okay fair enough fine yeah I
understand this other livestream asking
why are these ESP things so different
yep because the instruction set is
different so that's a specific reason
why I mean we just haven't created
something that we're gonna get two
instruction sets so let's go we're
coming there yeah we're getting there
okay okay generate the code compile it
download it yep I get that especially
with the deed with the sunglasses those
guys okay okay no time code execution
yes I understand
and I suppose you're going to talk about
analysis of code to make sure you hit
certain targets yeah a data object where
you can see some metrics I say so it can
say guaranteed to get this executed by a
certain amount of time okay don't run it
because you're gonna run it yeah okay
okay so this is this is an outline of
what's supposed to happen so there's so
much yeah so you know where it's used
and by different groups how it sort of
fits in to them what is it that we
provide them you know so we take
basically these systems objects that we
have built for control and signal
processing we can take those and if you
have one of those objects we automate
everything from there on out if you see
where I'm saying yeah I got it I mean I
would have called this function
microcontroller embed code because in
the bytecode family and it's about
microcontrollers but yeah I mean that's
a detail okay yeah it's based on the
function embed code so the design is
also I'm aware yeah right
so I we just named it that but this
details
okay so now here what you're saying is
this is the embed target you don't quite
know what this is
that's the port that's the mechanism
through which it goes to the target okay
so the first time element is what goes
the second argument is the details of
where it goes and the third is how it
gets that that's the intermediate right
but this is a parameter basically if
they Arduino Uno this is a parameter
yeah and so the second are this we can
get to the design in the in the ref page
so the second argument has three sub
arguments the first is the name of the
target the second is the water the input
pins or ports and this one has none and
the third is the output and I should
only think that should be an association
you're gonna do it that way it could be
I I even think that the whole of this
ball of wax should be could be an
association because I think that that I
could imagine all kinds of funky things
where this is for example Wi-Fi
connected rather than a dev anything the
third argument is an association and
this is just a synthetic okay the second
argument is also a list yeah we'll get
to that
yeah it's something close to what you
have in mind yeah okay terrific
okay so let's keep going here so this is
I mean this state space model thing so
the models here kind of close to trivial
a I'm saying yeah I understand I mean I
I but my question is well what you're
gonna get to is what kind of code can
live there yes it's it's very limited
but it's also exactly you know that's
what they are limited okay
so I'm saying but there's no need
particularly for anything very general
for goodness sake with a clock frequency
given in units 16 megahertz please all
right okay we have units let's use them
we might consider using units for the
for the size source code size 1 4 3 9
bytes possibly not sure about that
that's less certain about that okay
let's take a look at this so this shows
both the M the code generation and also
the device framework working in tandem
okay so let's take a look at this so
what you're showing here is there's a
filter now we see that the to discrete
time is sampling a continuous filter to
make it a sample system I don't really
understand well we're gonna get to that
these these various control system
models basically how they relate to just
arbitrary code and how they relate to
things like interpolating functions and
things like that
yes oh yeah you can you can see you that
object will also give you the source
code and then you can see the
corresponding code for that
okay options fine okay so let's take a
look here okay hoping a serial
connection yeah we what the heck is all
this stuff
yeah so we're setting up an input and so
this is something Roger and I discussed
we need to actually get a higher level
function so we're not doing so many
functions to read and write using the
device framework yeah it seems kind of
crazy so I mean you've got a serial port
so we have an idea for that for how to
streamline that but it's not there when
this okay let's just think about this
for a second so what is actually going
on here so you're trying to okay to
understand you have to look at what was
embedded above so if you look at M bit
microcontroller code above it tells what
the inputs and outputs are so one input
is coming to serial and the other one is
going okay fine fine so those are the
that's what's happening in the
microcontroller
and this is actually using testing the
microcontroller for exactly yeah okay
fine so this is seen well it actually
does what it says it was supposed to do
okay so this is rather grotesquely I
mean ultimately what you're doing here
is we are reading the input and then
sending the next we're reading the input
the output of them from them from the
odd VI and so you're doing a cycle where
it's you know read write read write so
it's almost like a continuous task I
mean in the case where I mean you you
could as well be thinking of this may be
I mean I don't know how it ends
how does this end how does it how does
it know how many is that
SP thing the thing that there's a
schedule task with its executing then
then finally we we stop the task oh I
see this is it so you're actually so
this is in fact a continuous task except
that you're using a scheduled task to do
a continuous task because we don't have
continuous tasks at this time it's
scheduled based on the sampling of that
microcontroller this because we sampled
it at that range oh I see I see I see
okay all right fine so device read time
series would be another thing that is
essentially reading so what you want is
device read/write time series or
something yeah yeah that roughly what
the functionality you're talking about
yes I forgot the name we said I I
discussed this with Igor at some point
yes baby well tentatively just for the
sake of me understanding it yeah it's
that it's device read yet I'm serious
weed right well so is that exactly the
function you and you guys invented yes
with a different name and we also have a
yeah design spec for that it's not
implemented okay fine all right let's
keep going
what the heck is this okay oh how it's
related to the other projects okay what
I want to know though is how um how does
this right toward we know like yeah yeah
so we explain so Arduino link is part of
the device framework so and why do I not
why am I not finding it that's just the
craziest thing okay all right fine okay
so in this in this framework we're
opening a connection and then reading or
writing configuring it and so on
wait and there's a there is a connection
back to the wolfram session okay so so
this here but this has some ability to
send code correct yeah it sends code yes
so how does that relate why I guess I'm
gonna see the design that you're
proposing for sending code because we
actually want to have some external code
representation and we've had several
projects working on that and I think for
example the the gnu compiler
representation with type specifications
is a much better way to do this
possibly but but sort of i don't think
it's gonna land on them because when are
they ever gonna want to do 8-bit
processors it's just not gonna be in
this well maybe so but I think
syntactically we want to use those same
structures well I understand I
understand it okay all right
it may make sense because that one is
isolated to the first argument so any
wolfin language code that comes in the
first argument of embed microcontroller
code if that can be handled by a
compiler we can get an equal in C++
representation that we can take and
cross compile on colleges all right fine
okay so now what do you got it okay
let's go to the guide page here
oops you need external fat do I need
external and unfortunately external some
external version was not working
properly here it doesn't need to be
super fresh if you ever no it was not
starting so so I'm gonna need external
I'm just gonna need the latest docu
tools why oh it's built so I could
actually look at it yeah okay so what am
i what am I looking just just open a
healthier and then you can keep okay
yeah and type a microcontroller code or
em but microcontroller code except it's
barely microcontroller code like that
right yeah it's in I don't trust any
searching up there do guide slash okay
what do you want me to do guide whatever
is under that link do you remember it's
it's it's microcontroller kit guide okay
okay I see it this is barely echoed my
keystrokes cuz I guess it's been
developed actually developed so guide
slash microcontroller kit unless I
misspelled that is not being found
no it's microcontroller kit slash guide
slash microcontroller kit there's a
microcontroller kit up front also you're
right okay now the first thing that here
that's called work since they're really
projects like little projects that you
can do is worth looking at I don't think
it should be called work foes no it's
absolutely possible be called work flows
is that a function name is that a
proposed function name no no so fine
okay okay it's just like so click on one
of these and you can see sort of the
there's nice documentation yeah we and
so there's typically like parts and how
you build it and then the various steps
okay let me look through this great it
will it'll leads and user step-by-step
to replicate this so it's useful if
somebody wants to do fright so I mean
does this match the workflow
documentation style yeah that's that's a
little yeah so there are little rough
edges because they because we see some
different style of workflow if you think
it's a different thing I mean if if the
either you've got to match the workflow
documentation style or you've got to
decide it's your own thing it's a kind
of a maker workflow or something I
suspect it will be better to match the
workflow documentation style okay
because in the work for there is no that
big introduction this is some of the
things we can change but there is that
not useful to have that introduction
yeah you might want to call this
something different you might want to
call it something like microcontroller
workflow I don't know what should be we
have similar things for the unity link
you know like little projects that you
can do yeah I don't know whether these
are you're saying these are more
projects than they are kind of you'll
want to do this often type workflows yes
yes I think that there's this they're
kind of like yeah there's step by step
projects these projects here's how you
do it do it yourself sample project or
something right yeah sample project is
not a bad but it's but that's what they
are fine then that's what we should
consider using
um look at the few of them Steven okay
some of them a little bit more elaborate
because there are more parts that you
need to get okay so this is the one way
you have that whole big just streamlined
yeah okay let's go back up here drive a
robot along apart okay
a beautiful zone spikey yeah aren't we
lucky that our rhombic like secondo he'd
ruin can be zone constructed right um
okay this one has the DC motor I know
has more parts to it says oh yeah this
works okay don't forget the batteries
what we are exhaustive so should be
stacked upside down on it weird okay so
this is definitely a sample project this
is hardly a part of a grant workflow
that people are gonna need when they
build you know landers for Saturn's
moons or something that's right um okay
it's a bit grotesque what's all this
doing yeah this is just assembling
getting the libraries
it's really quite weird
okay what is I mean
viewed in terms of ordinary code so if I
want to have a microcontroller where it
receives I mean are they mostly they're
getting digital inputs yes so the way
that this is typically done is that you
write C code that does every step or a
thing read this do that but there's no
design you don't design using that you
just do the actual code make the
microprocessor I understand but it's
already got it's got a 2 D on the input
so yeah so microcontrollers usually have
a 2 D D to a converters built in okay
they have analog inputs actually okay
fine so so I mean naively I could have a
function a microcontroller that just you
know squares a number or something yeah
yes so what would happen is voltage of
you know 2 volts would come in and 4
volts would come out yeah yes okay so so
in our representation I mean we're using
state space models and things like that
to represent what's actually going on
inside the microcontroller to get a
limited world you know the more you know
we might want to build that out but I
think that we don't know how much to
invest in this area yet you know and
this is we think this is the most
important case to use the compiler for
example we could we certainly know what
functions are being used because we know
if they're in the RTL we know where they
are you know etcetera etcetera etcetera
we know what what's involved I think to
think there could be a future version
where we do use sort of more of a
compiler infrastructure but you know we
can get a year's worth of interesting
feedback and use by providing this in
learning more about sort of the essence
of use cases ok what is a state space
model I mean sort of mathematically what
what is that it is when you have
system of first order differential
equations or first-order difference
equations mm-hmm so the only thing you
need to do is to you know let's take a
discrete case but a first system of
first order difference equation it just
means that x1 a time step k plus 1
equals a function of the states that
debrief at k it's the time okay fine you
know and and that's what it is
so essentially what what you're saying
is the microcontroller is going to
execute the it's going to step through
these differential equations based on
the that are receiving so it needs to be
discrete it needs to be difference
equations so even if you model it using
differential equation you are
responsible for discretizing it and
making it difference equations so state
space model then you say states exist
both differential equations and
difference equations the ones that the
microcontroller ultimately wants is its
difference equations because it needs to
do things step by step you know okay I'm
back all right based model so sniffing
let me said so if you want to really see
what the state space model in terms of
code I think you just look at that first
work flow the first project or even the
DC motor and if you look at the source
code you'll see the equivalent stay C
code representation for that the first
one for example and then if we
discretize and deploy the filter and and
then go down and and just copy that
microcontroller code data object and if
you do need some microcontroller kit and
ask for the source code it will it will
show you what was that equivalent source
code for that discretized transfer
function model but first you gotta do
needs much
and then ask for source code property
yeah and you see update TFM that metal
down there's an update
yes so that is the
my gosh what is all this job killer yes
so that that setting up getting the
serial data and so on
that's an intra protein that's getting
that receiving that's receiving that
yeah
this is all that we automate for the
user so right but this is the actual
model up here yeah that update TFM
that's what is getting updated at zero
when I do this here can I see the point
oh two whatever or is that it should be
there so yeah this has been somehow yes
because if you do a transfer function
expand on that probably that's what okay
okay I understand we see the denominator
there but the numerator has gotten
expanded okay okay fine all right so
let's go back yeah what we're looking at
okay so the stage might be guide page
for what good overview oh no wherever
you want to go Stephen the guide page
for this is back out of that project
file you come back to the guide page
there okay okay so now okay so we've got
these various system models which you
tell me are they essentially these
differential equations that turn into
difference equations yeah and that's
what when you hear us talking about that
in signal processing in control we say
it's a continuous-time model it's a
discrete time model continuous time
means differential equations discrete
time means difference equations okay so
that's the discretization yes yes
okay and these are okay fine so now
what's this this is how you wire
together these use objects okay right so
you can now what's the relationship
between filters and I mean if filter is
some theater is a you know they all
represented as transfer function models
mm-hmm so it's it's using the same sort
of system representation now the filter
has an input and it gets transformed to
an output that's exactly what a control
system is to you know yeah they are all
that they take some inputs they have
some little memory and they have an
output but so these filters are
operating a frequency domain or what
typically now in the time domain and you
know so Butterworth filter correspond to
set you know continuous time it's a set
a differential equation discrete time
it's a set of difference equations okay
so tells you what it does to the signal
okay okay and if I look at those random
things that you had in the first page
and I look at the code that they have in
them I mean like like I don't know the
flight controller for a drone is it
representable in terms of these things
yes so how complicated is it typically
but the person what Stephen means by
that super but yeah so so typically at
the very low level they have those
controllers are obtained by putting
together these different models mm-hmm
yeah but they'll also have one slightly
advanced thing where they have finite
state machines that which we don't have
yet but these are what comprise those
controllers or filters these are these
basic systems models okay but but I mean
so you know
if i were to look at the code how long
is the code typically for about what
filter it's a few kilobytes the entire
thing getting drier what about for
something like you know a drone
hoverboard something like that what what
are the sizes of code and how many weird
exceptions do they have in them and how
much of it is just you know how do you I
just don't know what code looks like I
mean in the case of you know standard
kinds of so so the core still looks very
much like what you looked at mm-hmm okay
what can happen in particular for flight
because it's a fairly nonlinear process
is that you have many of those so under
these conditions we use this simple
model on the designer conditions we use
this adder you know so for even even the
Boeing you know has that you know Boeing
passenger jet yes for the core flight
control they are everything is a little
bit more complex but let's say they have
thirty of those models that run for
different parts of the envelope typical
actual number that's an actual number
that I knew from some while ago not from
now but from my previous life and you
think it's not what you think it's gonna
think it's I think it's it's grown in a
variety of ways Boeing had a you take
into account more information you know
so that the the what's called the order
of the model the number of states in
that wreck difference equation is higher
okay you know so their model more
details but so I mean the typical thing
would be you know if the plane is within
I don't know if if the plane is at
38,000 feet and it's a certain so the
envelope is typically parametrized by
speeding height you know and you can use
more elaborate sort of a plane I mean if
it puts its flaps down and things does
that change I mean the configuration of
the control surfaces and things does
that change it too
no the flight the flight in just these
parameters like like angle of attack
okay at the height and so on okay
and then there are hard limits on how
how far the control surfaces can go yeah
but then okay but so the flight
controller is controlling ultimately
it's controlling I say it's controlling
the control surfaces then like it's
flipping yeah yeah okay um and I see I
see I get it but I mean it's presumably
matters whether you know where the
wheels are down or not or things like
that which is not something the flight
controller is going to figure out I mean
it's not going to do that it's somebody
else is gonna put the wheels down
presumably maybe not so anymore right
but but that might mean that that that
that's what I'm saying is there might be
more parameters to determine how many of
these models this dynamics changed when
we also down fair enough okay fine but
so so the organization so I mean with
the stuff that we're describing here
somebody would write I mean what does
the if look like to say if the plane is
in transonic flight then do whatever
what does the if look like in this
system is that one we don't we're not
doing that particularly we can do some
if but not the case that you decide
describe where we really kind of
effectively have you know like in the
case we describe like 30 of these states
based models that are tied together in a
state machine from this you go to here
to here to here okay depending on
conditions so we can't do that we can't
do that very easily what limits us is we
don't have a model representation to
hold that description we can do that in
the future I'm just saying that this is
fine so we're dealing with a single one
of those you know conditions right base
model for a single one of those
conditions we're not dealing with a
transition from one right condition to
another that's right so it's it's as if
I mean if we were doing if these things
were interpolating functions or neural
nets for that matter I mean we've known
that so I don't think we've had that
issue
particularly yet you know for example
for example you could well imagine
something where it says you know ok
initially run a classifier that says
whether it's an aerial photograph or a
microscope image sure and based on that
just you know use this object recognizer
rather than that one right I don't think
we've quite set that up yet right yes so
once we have that description be able to
describe this in the Wolfram language
it'll be useful for this functionality
too we can just there's no there's no
barrier per se Steven if we it's better
that we have it as a high-level
description in the language then we can
actually design it manipulate it and do
things so ok so what is it so this is
this is yes so this is for a way for the
user to know what we support okay so
this is where the question that we had
about ESP things would be a future thing
to support or something is that right
yeah but everybody here is using C code
and that's using some kind of compiler
so the vendor of the microcontroller
does provide a compiler mm-hmm
because otherwise it's very hard to use
product so they mean they need to get
that you know so yes so we have
extensive tutorials but if we go step by
step how to set it up and so on ok so
there's a I mean in the modern world of
external evaluator there's this notion
of system install which is like if you
want to install you know a Python system
or something there's a system install of
the Python system so you get version
whatever it is we haven't done that but
we that would be nice if we can get that
set up ok so that you could plug into
the system install mechanism possibly
you know I just don't know whether that
requires legal agreement with the
different vendors to be able to do that
and there's a lot of I would suspect
that no I think you're just taking you
know it might come from their website or
whatever else but it's just we're just
packaging it so that you just use this
one function and it will install what
you need yeah but we've
problems in other places where they sort
of change where it's you're not allowed
to do that because the user needs to
provide you know yeah yeah right yeah
right I understand where there's a
click-through license for example if for
example um okay so although we do have a
mechanism for dealing with that I
believe I believe we have that for
example up for our service connections
we have that mm-hmm okay so I'm trying
to understand so the C code that gets
generated that you were showing me there
is never a symbolic representation of
that anyway it's not like this case
where we have some kind of custom
symbolic representation of the C code
that we downloaded into the
microcontroller is that right yeah yeah
that is not part of it although we can
we can inject it with external libraries
no but I'm asking you are using symbolic
C or not under the hood it's using so
when you load microcontroller kit it
loads symbolic C and that's how we
generate the C code
using that Stephen at some point there
internally that's what is being done
symbolic C is generating the C code for
these microcontrollers there is another
thing so you want to marshal the
compilation and then then actually
getting the code compiled code on there
is its own little thing the loader for
these things are it's not what you think
of is sort of in a computer with an
operating system Stephen yeah just one
second
I'm sorry
back back up good so let's say that
you've compiled it then you need to get
the code actually on dem microcontroller
somehow yeah I guess that right that's
what this is doing that's what this
device configure thing is doing it's
going upload right of the code to the
microcontroller yes yeah it's doing it
through a serial connection I understand
how else are you doing how are you doing
yeah so so yeah so so this one is
opening a connection to the device and
maintained I see it right
yes but we are not we are giving it to
the to the third party tool chain if you
look at that original diagram it's just
a one-time deployment that workflow that
it was in the first slide slide show my
first slide show
the first slide in the in the slide show
it's Paris okay just keep yeah this one
you see after we generate the source
code then we give give it to the
third-party tool chain and it's just a
one time before I see that from the
embed code output how would that work
you know that's happening behind the
scenes it's it's doing a run process
it's calling those things and deploying
how does I mean look physically the
microcontroller has to be connected to
your computer somehow or you can't send
squat to it yeah yes yeah so that's the
other difference between this one and
Arduino link so you can do that that
workflow that exists an Arduino link
because we can connect with an Arduino
because an Arduino has two things it has
a bootloader on the on the chip and it
also has a USB to serial converter not
every micro point if you just have a
bare metal microcontroller it doesn't
have that so right so we have what's
called a hardware so for so in the
general case we have what's called the
hardware programmer again it's in that
workflow that diagram now I understand
but I want to see it in the in the case
that you okay so you have here one of
these let's try one of these things here
okay so embed the code so in this case
microcontroller code data is some
symbolic representation of the
embeddable code is that correct so it
has two things so it shows that it first
generated the code that's the two LEDs
that we're trying to show and then and
and then it also says that it has been
deployed how does it deploy it so what
wouldn't you say needs my computer how
do I tell it that I have some weird
little thing connected with wires yeah
exactly that's the third argument of a
microcontroller code so the Arduino
because I say I get it so that is that
is basically whatever the configuration
thing is it's putting it out on that dev
TTY exactly so if it's an Arduino Uno
you just have to say that and the others
are we all look like when it's an IPA
and a Wi-Fi system yeah you can look at
em but microcontroller code and in the
details section we show that different
keys of that Association
so the third argument as I said was
actually an association so if you look
at em both microcontroller code and in
the details section this is getting into
the design of yeah if you go down not
yeah this is the third argument yeah so
the programming so the see we can say
what is the connection port what is the
program are we using various the what is
what is the program what does that mean
that's so that's a tool chain that's
actually the program is actually a
hardware device the programmer is
actually a soft the external programmer
is the hardware and programmer is the
software okay so that's the name yeah
that's what they're called the
programmers we probably they communicate
through certain pins on the on the on
the microcontroller to probe to put it
into different place locations in the
microcontroller boy this is a
complicated set up so cool
I mean the thing I'm trying to
understand is okay there's also a
tutorial which shows that in detail okay
I'm trying to understand in in so this
is a much more rural thing that relies
on the fact that not we know has a
certain communication connectivity
mechanism built into it exactly yeah
so that's why you're able to say device
open like that not every micro
controller you can device open from yeah
right because it doesn't have any way of
communicating with the world exactly
yeah only this programmer thing can
communicate with it yeah yeah
why don't I please spell out
configuration you've got so many big
words here you can spell out
configuration okay um okay oh okay fine
so let me ask a few other bizarre
questions okay like if somebody wanted
to use this in a very lightweight way
does it make any sense to use it in the
cloud I understand that you can't
connect let's say you met you you used
it in the cloud you use this as and then
you download to your computer something
which is some kind of package that you
then feed to your programmer thing and
it then does the program is I'm just
trying to understand if we wanted to
provide this for example to
manufacturers of microcontrollers and we
said here's this cloud-based you know
design space where in the end of it you
just press a button and it splits out a
file you know it got something rather
file and then that's what you just load
somehow onto your into your
microcontroller programmer does that
make any sense yeah because the Arduino
already has that where they can download
from the cloud right - right - the dard
we know we just don't connect the cloud
to the because even a device framework
besson go from the cloud to the actual
physical port that's why we've held off
but that yeah that's that's possible
okay that's interesting so hold on let
me let me try to understand what you
just said so I mean in general
downloading I mean the cloud to reach an
IOT device for example one of the main
problems is what is the address of that
IOT device and how do you open firewalls
and things to the point where the cloud
can squirt something out and have it end
up in the IOT device yeah right yeah
and that remains a stupid unsolved
problem of the IOT world as how that
authentication works yes yeah but just
talking about the Arduino it's
yep we should be able to go from the
cloud because the cloud doesn't talk to
the actual ports on this machine but we
should be able to just say in the cloud
that you know I'm running it on this
machine yes and and download it what do
i download it's some kind of bundle of
stuff that then goes to the programmer
that yeah yeah the cloud should have
this third-party tool chain it should
have the programmer also yeah then it's
not doable i I don't know yeah it is
because Ardoin already has that because
they have no that's a complicated
licensing story right no no it's this is
all complicated licensing if you want to
do that right I mean but not for us but
for a you know a vendor of
microcontrollers they could do this if
they had a private cloud instance of our
cloud they could do this they could host
such a thing correct yes it's
interesting and there are they're
comparable things out there other than
for the Arduino yes yes I think the ETA
also has it okay Arduino okay for like
God we know see or are they for things
like you know I here's a Butterworth
filter yes yes yes for that in yes
that's what we provide so you know if
you go an Arduino well then we have they
have to generate manually get the
equivalent code for the Butterworth
filter okay so fine so I mean what what
we could see right well we could provide
is something where you go from a
notebook in the in our cloud or in a
private instance of our cloud to the
actual bundle of stuff that needs to be
downloaded to the microcontroller but
the the last step there requires going
through the programmer software of the
microcontroller vendor yeah that right
yes yes
that's interesting so okay so then and
and when people program okay fair enough
and I mean one of the nice things here
obviously is that one can have notebooks
that basically specify a bunch of like
your sample projects here that specify a
bunch of code and that if they were
configured correctly it could just be
there's a notebook in the cloud it just
talks about Butterworth filters at the
end it just has some function that just
says okay give me the file you know run
it through the programmer thing and give
me the file and that's essentially your
microcontroller embed code thing right
because the the okay the current embed
code function does not do what you were
doing here the current embed code
function but gives you a thing that you
essentially copy paste to whatever
environment you're using it doesn't do
it could use pub/sub for example to
actually inject the you know the code or
whatever do you get what I'm saying so
okay we are using the programmer to
inject the code into the microcontroller
I understand what you're saying I'm
saying I'm saying that and you're
specifying a port to do that on right
yes yeah I'm saying there are two steps
so embed code right the normal embed
code not your embed code but the normal
embed code in the system does not do
that right you know okay I get what
you're saying so that's exactly what
we're showing with two steps here
because even embed microcontroller code
is a two-step process in generates the
code I get and then we can take that
code and then yeah and then yeah we can
just generate that code hold it and then
invoke something later and deploy it
right which is what you're doing with
the microcontroller code data thing is
that correct yeah so this one gues
combines both those steps into one yeah
right
but what I'm arguing is so the point
that I'm making your microcontroller
code data thing is okay in the case of
ordinary embed code right for JavaScript
for example you actually get a
of JavaScript code that you can see in
the notebook yeah you copy/paste yeah
yeah okay now we have not done the
connection we looked at doing these
connections into Ige's and things where
instead of using copy/paste to transport
that code you use some other kind of
mechanism yeah because because in our
case it would just be using that code
data getting the source code and and
then linking it however to the IDE
because we that code data gives gives
the source code so sorry I supposed to
hold on one second so the embed code
gives this gives say for example the the
other languages code which we can use in
the IDE right yep so here also from that
microcontroller code data we can get the
source code which was cool so that's the
C code which you could in principle just
copy paste and stick into some kind of
yeah so if it's an at my if it's a
microchip thing you can you could you
could stick it in there and then compile
it from there right you could manually
do those last steps and sometimes you do
because you want a tweak you want to add
something
I understand we might want that as but
okay but then the workflow that you were
imagining is when you feed that C code
to the programmer I find these names
very confusing yes they are confusing
from there's no more decorated version
of the word programmer um so that I
don't it doesn't remind me of everybody
who you know human yeah right um well
anyway this is the one I think maybe
okay fine all right so let's say we'll
call it the microcontroller programmer
um let's say that you okay but what
you're telling me is the output of the
microcontroller program is what a blob
of binary stuff yeah it's a bits of
binary so the
it goes it goes so sorry so it goes to
several stages so it it has some binary
stuff and also the address where it
should go in the microcontroller and so
on and then the programmer takes it and
puts it at those addresses computer that
I used yeah this is very low level that
when you get down to it yeah this is
very close to that Steven and you know
because it it effectively has you know
it's it's bare metal right it's not a
relocatable binary it's at a fixed
address etc etc etc yeah and by the way
you you you've said that because you
have a clock frequency there you can say
for the microcontroller code data you
can say what the execution time is and
things like that is that correct
yeah that's the sampling period in the
model okay so we say how how what is the
rate at which we want this to execute I
understand may not succeed right you you
might have over text but that particular
hardware can deliver but can we simulate
that can we tell you yeah that week yeah
so that the only way to find out is if
the microcontroller acts weirdly because
there's no way to because it has to do a
certain number of instructions within
that time period how do we know that
whether it has been it was really
implemented because there is code that
we can actually simulate but yeah but
that's that would be too much work for
us yeah okay fair enough okay all right
so so I'm trying to understand so the
thing that you are saying we could do is
we could have something you know in the
cloud notebook based kind of design that
then could be connected to the
microcontroller programmer of some
particular vendors microcontroller then
the result is you press a button and out
comes this binary file which you know
you can like download from your web
browser and then somehow you have to get
that binary file into the
microcontroller because and you could
potentially do that because Mike
controller is connected to dev TTY blah
blah blah on your computer it might be
better to get the C code version of it
yeah because there's some dependence
there because they have different
headers and other things but
nevertheless it's fairly neutral and
those those environments where you edit
C code they usually integrate it so
programmers so it's like the IDE
situation that I referred to earlier if
those ideas have api's of some kind or
have some pub/sub mechanism then you can
potentially you know auto inject the
code into the IDE that or you can follow
the copy/paste model that you described
yeah it's fine
what we supply here is a more automated
tool chain yeah I understand if you
happen to you're right right but I'm
saying I think you should break it apart
or allow it to be broken apart the hooks
exist so it's just a question of you
know if if we can work this out with
those vendors and and then we can inject
into their IDs right I mean that's what
I said we don't necessarily need to
inject it into the IDE we can do that
sabi paste you know this is automating
so much stuff you can survive with one
copy-paste well this is very cool so
what I mean you know there's presumably
some detailed design stuff here Roger
probably gone over it I've gone over it
me you have opinions you know but I also
want to make clear for us I think it's
important that we limit and you know how
far we go until we sort of get feedback
from what people type signature thing
yes so these are some things that
because this one needs the type to just
like all these other things so what what
is the name we should call it because we
because embed code calls it external
type segments I've seen a bunch of names
around there is audio type here in our
Arduino link it's return type then there
is even data type in the system there
are all kinds of type names well I mean
clearly in the compiler
it's the typed type it is the is the
general ramp
it's vrat but it's a rapper right yeah I
understand what you want is what is this
a type for it's for what the data type
is and whether it's an int or unsigned
8-bit int and so on the data type for
what that's that's expected to be in the
C code that the C code is expecting yeah
variables and on the ATD converters and
things like that as a microcontroller No
so so so those inputs and outputs of
those of the system model what we want
them to be no I understand that but but
when it's running on the microcontroller
the input is coming from some port that
you know some wire some pin yeah that
has presumably an A to D converter
yeah and and that is usually and it's it
can be you can go up 2024 so it's some
value like that
okay would like to convert into a raw
value like 5 volts or 3.3 volts or maybe
we like to store it as an int storage as
an in test so the question is when the
input comes in I mean I'm sure these
microcontrollers have endless options
for how that works on endless different
ways that the agent Steven can I make
you look at a few more I assumed that we
would get back to this can I ask you to
just click on that web page markup down
there you know
the document for there it's all the way
it's important oh yeah sorry this is a
mock-up click on the magnifier you see
it so first of all couple of things
we've demoed this at various trade shows
we have a beta test running right now
but it doesn't beta testers okay and we
want to open up partnerships and we have
some contacts but but you would have
something to show them which we have now
and so clearly this joint interest its
interest from most interest from the
microcontroller makers and the micro
board makers yeah I should probably
I dunno some people in the space you
should write that in a separate separate
discussion absolutely um actually know
several people who I'd be super
interested in this good but I'm figuring
I'm glad that we covered what we were
able to cover so far but clearly I know
you know we need to go back to this one
more so yeah but I think this is fine to
get I mean you know if this is presented
as a thing and development I don't see
why we shouldn't have this page out
there you know where it says it's a beta
version or whatever else it wants to say
mm-hmm preview or something like this
probably preview is the better term
because you know the things we're gonna
want to change but I understand I do
think it's worth explaining the workflow
of going through the cloud because I
think that's a really interesting worked
well I don't really want to add in dicks
out at this point because that'sthat's
another well fair enough but
partnerships should certainly understand
that yeah um yeah I'm interesting I mean
but why don't you show in this case here
yeah you've got to be able to show where
that comes from because that's what
that's what's really exciting is that
that isn't you know that just looks like
I know what the heck that looks like
there but what you've got to show is
that you can compute you know the the
first example should show how you
actually go from the Butterworth filter
to the thing that or whatever whatever
you want to call it you know having
there to something which is you know a
kind of what can I say as a sort of you
know scientifically motivated thing or
something - something which
automatically generates the code etc
right are you talking about that that
image just there yeah I'm talking about
this example I'm saying your first
example should have something which
makes it clearer and I would suggest
having call-outs in it that basically
say bring another accent because this
example is super simple so I'm saying
this is like this is like hello world
right but I'm suggesting that you have
an example even in the simplest case you
have an example where this thing here
actually visibly has something which you
can I mean even if you just wrote that
out a state space model of blah blah
blah or whatever it is no help because
otherwise I don't know what the heck
that is this trip yesterday
misunderstood that yeah that was me okay
it was you know it just looks like an
extraterrestrial spacecraft that landed
there and you can't tell where it came
from
that's true like I get it I get it so a
much simpler point than I thought right
um yeah I mean this is very interesting
it's nice you should have showed me this
page first probably maybe I wouldn't
have understood it well I think that
taking the journey that we did was good
you know there's many other ways we
could have done it but well I think I
understand what the story is here I I
think I can even point you to some
interesting partnership connections
um this is great the other side is that
there are there millions of users of
this first of all but all of these
microcontroller makers and micro board
van
have also communities that we can
directly reach which is gay but I mean I
assume that some of those companies are
also trying to work on you know neural
net deployment things and I know since
we have a tool chain that involves you
know where we can't generate like neural
net stuff that's I mean you know I would
assume that some neurons you step up as
you start stepping up you know from
8-bit to 32-bit and other things and
yeah then then it becomes realistic to
deploy a little bit more right those
guys are actually moving down to smaller
bit accounts right I doubt that they're
gonna move below 32 bit for that's not
true it's not true absolutely yeah
absolutely there's a there's a there was
actually a kid at our summer school this
year who's trying to get a company
started that's based on very small bit
count there on that things yes 8-8
bitten and so on and has a whole bunch
of schemes for how to do that you alone
in your house probably have a hundred of
these running that you don't even know
about yes I understand that I understand
that and I'm about to do this big
project I've just been instrumenting my
HVAC system right that's what so that so
I'm gonna finally learn control theory
because I'm gonna experience it so to
speak yeah I mean I don't know you saw
that the the the initial data from
something this crazy thing that we're
switching itself on and off on and off
every five minutes know that there's
clearly a bug so and I think the actual
current control system is totally stupid
so I'm gonna see whether so we have some
raspberry PI's and things and they're
supposedly getting sensor data I have
some open language functions that read
the sensors and set the actuators and
now all that's needed is to actually put
in the control system so hopefully in a
couple of weeks I'll be in a position to
do that so I can then boil and freeze
you know under program control
in any way alright good stuff well very
nice great project and probably wanting
to look at some more details but this
looked really good ya know so I think
Steven I think we'll set one up for in a
week you come back and we'll try to them
then because then you know all the
context you get a sense of where it is
you're gonna need some repetition but
then we can nail the details that's fine
and we might want to also talk with the
partnerships focus at that time yeah
that might be a good idea - okay sounds
good
okay thank you thanks to folks on the
livestream as well see you later bye